John Rambo has finally met his match the
critics reviews are coming in for Rambo
last blood which brings an end to the
story begun with 1982's first blood the
general consensus Rambo deserved a
better send-off and one with much less
of a sadistic streak over-the-top
carnage is nothing new for this
franchise 2008's Rambo similarly turned
off critics with it's cartoonish
reliance on dishing up as much blood and
guts as humanly possible but last Bloods
detractors of which there were many were
taken aback not only by the extreme
level of the violence on display but by
some of the more troubling themes
implied by the film's plot which
involves Rambo crossing the border into
Mexico to search for a family friend who
has been kidnapped by sex traffickers
many of the flicks detractors noted that
political themes had always been present
in the Rambo series even perhaps
especially First Blood which dealt with
the mistreatment of Vietnam veterans
after they returned home from the war
but the series's worldview seems to have
changed with the times and not for the
better according to varieties Peter
debruge who wrote Rambo last blood is
another cruel and ugly showcase of
xenophobic carnage squeezed into barely
80 minutes and packaged for export the
screenwriters adopt the racist view of
Mexicans as murderers drug dealers and
rapists this character has always been a
mess of contradictions represented on
one hand the permanent damage that
military service can do to one soul
while simultaneously suggesting what the
ideal soldier looks like Rambo
single-handedly wins the wars that
America can't and the blood isn't likely
to stop here or anytime soon Tom Glasson
of concrete playground concurred using
that the level of violence presented in
last blood a step up even from 2008 to
Rambo and his estimation was better
suited for a different type of franchise
glass and wrote Rambo last blood a film
that aspires to be Logan yet lands
somewhere closer to the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre
Rambo abhors violence yet maintains a
terrifying arsenal of knives guns and
explosives and beneath this picturesque
branch is a straight up house of horrors
physically and psychologically but is
the film still enjoyable mostly no yet
still some reviewers were even less kind
like the Guardians Peter Bradshaw who
absolutely
leveled the picture in his reviews first
paragraph writing this massively
enlarged prostate of a film can only
make you wince with its badly acted
Toronto violence its trumpian fantasies
of Mexican rapists and hilariously
insecure us border and it's crass
enthusiasm for rape revenge attacks
undertaken by a still got it senior dude
seventy three years young on behalf of a
sweet teenager even some of the
reviewers who recommended the film
seemed to gasp that it's violence with
many remarking that even for a series
which is always hung its hat on wanton
bloodshed last blood is a bridge too far
Fred Topol of showbiz cheatsheet wrote
it's funny to think how these movies
were always symbols of Hollywood's
gratuitous violence they were bloody but
blood was the worst they could show in
the 80s last blood takes the violence so
far it almost has to be the last blood
because there's no more blood left
remember when the most graphic scene in
first blood was when he cleans his arm
wound with his knife again this was a
positive review which indicates that
even some of those predisposed to expect
in a heaping helping of bloody mayhem
got a little bit more than they
bargained for other critics posting
positive reviews seem to recommend the
flick in spite of themselves
Vince Mancini of aprox for example
penned an assessment which read for all
the world like an absolute evisceration
of the film right up until the point
where the critic offered his endorsement
Trump era Rambo is essentially a human
border wall keeping out Mexican rapists
and murderers it's so genuinely horrific
I'm convinced there are real-life cartel
videos celebrating the torture of rivals
that are less gory
I was either howling with nervous
laughter or covering my face the entire
time this movie is the product of truly
deranged Minds it's a must-see one thing
viewers shouldn't expect is for the film
to do justice to its iconic main
character this idea was summed up most
succinctly by Harry Garen of RTE who
wrote this last post for the 37 year old
franchises at cheap and rushed send-off
there are plenty of bodies but not much
soul and although this is by far the
bloodiest of Rambo's rampages it's also
the least cathartic don't remember him
this way check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite films are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]